[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh inches in their County mpg why we be
and they go shake my other rocket stupid
[Music]
you are to would think it what you
[Music]
[Music]
it's never suitors
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my problem bigger these boys yeah Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
my boobs are we kidnap don't ball I
can't repeat my face a coupon
[Music]
would you what you were sneaking what
you must've reached the Kobe Bryant in
his daughter blood they met that labor
try to stop nickel crystal
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like Superman
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no wonder in their face me she don't
wanna bring the weight remember Chris
cause I wanna hold me down I make your
dreams come true
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe that's only me
[Music]
[Applause]
Chicago
sing it Leon
[Music]
when they come for you I will Shield's
your name I will feel their questions I
will no one can
[Music]
they don't know I'm moving on my shadow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's make it so this is my
[Music]
the first
[Music]
my head
[Music]
[Applause]
we play for a day
that'll come when we get to see the
place where there is no sunrise and
there is no sunset and the Prince of
Peace will say job well done
back in time I lost track of time
rolling on the road Christmas season
Valentine's seem like the days before I
came
[Music]
but I almost miss my be ain't nowhere
greater ain't nowhere brighter ain't
nowhere better
[Music]
ain't no one wiser
ain't no one
[Music]
[Applause]
a Milano's we will this all here
he knows the mo how do we treat each
other I was
[Music]
now I'm just
[Music]
I was
[Music]
steady
I grow weary and old we're as close as
well
I was gone I had places to
you're
[Music]
ain't nowhere cradle ain't nowhere
brighter ain't no better
ain't no one prettier
ain't no one wiser ain't no better
and are still standing
[Music]
I was a RocknRolla back in my day
and now I'm just arrived
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen let's have one more
big round of applause for chance the
rapper